Bueno estamos hablando de cuatro
regiones que representan aproximadamente
el 15% del territorio
ucraniano qué cree usted que busca Rusia
con estos referendos Más allá de hacerse
con parte del territorio
Bueno buenas tardes Muchas gracias por
la invitación sí efectivamente no es
solo control territorial es básicamente
la consolidación de una de unos logros
militares y sobre todo desde el punto de
vista de Vladimir Putin es una respuesta
a unas exigencias de los nacionalistas
rusos a los cuales de alguna forma las
derrota parcial de Rusia les ha
molestado muchísimo Entonces por un lado
digamos muchos esfuerzos que trataban de
Resaltar las debilidad de de Vladimir
Putin lo que estás tratando de hacer con
esto es garantizar o demostrar su
compromiso con la causa y con el
esfuerzo militar que está haciendo ahora
por otro lado digamos es una forma de
garantizar que nos sigan perdiendo
porque tal como ya se Seguramente se
discutirá más adelante el hecho de
incluir esos territorios dentro de Rusia
los pone detrás o debajo de una especie
de sombrilla nuclear rusa garantizando
que Ucrania no tenga la posibilidad real
de recuperarlos por la fuerza
Jesús qué cree que se viene después de
las consultas qué ocurrirá concretamente
en estas regiones
concretamente habrá una transformación
digamos habrá obviamente una nueva
autoridad es bastante posible que no se
creen cuatro regiones nuevas dentro de
de de Rusia posiblemente lugares que
tenías que sí tengan tengan
Independencia pero las zonas y de gerson
seguramente eran parte de una nueva
estructura administrativa digamos
asociada con crimen pero digamos será
una nueva situación en la cual será
nuevos sujetos federados dentro de Rusia
donde la aplicarán empezar a aplicar la
ley rusa y el gran temor que surge Es
que la misma población dentro de esos
territorios se ha movilizada para
defender incluso por la fuerza esos
territorios ante un esfuerzo ucraniano
por recuperarlo Y si bien la cifras
oficiales de Rusia sobre estos
resultados por supuesto pueden generar
desconfianza no existe en estas regiones
una tendencia general o alguna tendencia
a querer ser parte de Rusia
digamos Claro que no no se puede negar
que alguna que algunas personas de
descendencia rusa puedan tener tipo
pretensiones pero sin duda la gran
mayoría es abiertamente procraniana o
que buscaba buscaría mantenerse dentro
del territorio ucraniano y tal como lo
mencionaba muy bien es un referendo que
está organizando una autoridad político
militar impuesta por Moscú que se
encarga no solo de organizar sino llevar
a cabo y demás declarar los resultados
del referente y además hemos visto como
el mismo proceso es extremadamente
cuestionable por la forma como se
realizó es decir soldados pasando de
casa en casa y exigiendo que las
personas voten incluso enfrente de ellos
y eso hace que digamos la legitimidad
del resultado no se pueda no se pueda
justificar de ninguno de ninguna
perspectiva y segundo la tendencia
históricas que aunque Sí por supuesto
hay una población de descendencia rusa
la mayoría históricamente ha apoyado a
Ucrania y el gobierno tal como se venció
Incluso en el esfuerzo de por defender
ese territorio ante lanzaros